[Music]
it's time it's time it's time i can't
wait for this one this one i think i'm
gonna get you guys i'm gonna get you
guys for sure
okay so first this first one um
thank you to dr till for this one
by the way people are now sending me
things to torture you with i hope you
understand what is going on now so uh
here it is
first on up is a
movie trailer just for you guys enjoy
this movie trailer i hate his left this
movie trailer is called
haters laugh i hate his laugh this movie
trailer is called do revenge
i spent 17 years meticulously curating
the perfect life
i had the perfect friends the perfect
boyfriend okay yeah because here's the
thing when you say you have your pur but
your perfect friends
um
they all look like a bunch of douche
bags
so your friends [ __ ] suck and look i
know you're not supposed to judge a book
by its cover
but if the cover looks like this it's a
bad book
friends yeah perfect boyfriend maybe you
could send me something to keep me
company but you know where all of that
got me is this gonna be a leak sex tape
absolutely destroyed
i guess he posted it on pornhub
max ruined my life
he'll never get away with this
[Laughter]
right do you want to ride
i know what it's like
is that a lesbian is is because she went
out with max is she going to realize
that men are terrible and then the
little oh what's her face that's uma
thurman's daughter
oh my god it looks like her you is that
who it is yeah uma thurman and ethan
hawk's daughter maya hawk
i [ __ ] hate uma thurman
it's like to get [ __ ] over by someone
you thought you could trust carissa
jones she started in nasty i'm talking
like this because that makes this a deep
part of the movie you remember about me
she told everyone that i tried to hold
her down and kiss her
did you though hold on hold on but hold
on can i ask a question though
did you though did you didn't you though
can you not can you hear me though
sorry did you did what would you sorry i
have a speech impediment was there any
like photographs of this okay hands up
merch i don't trust it hands up
everybody apologize
you can't see us okay nope
great the jerky boys
i wish we could hire people to take them
down we should is this dirty work are
they doing dirty work is this dirty work
are they doing dirty work are they doing
dirty work are they going to [ __ ] on one
of the funniest man's barely in the
ground
no merch is this worse because they were
making it while he was alive
it's called do revenge
team up and do each other's revenge
oh no it's throw mama from the
throw mama from the train the mama from
the path train that one on screen is
definitely [ __ ]
thank you that was a good one thank you
thank you i was about to say stop her
i'll throw mama from the train that's
two different moves
this one over here she goes we have to
do each other's revenge okay but i think
what i should do is use poison ivy stop
pitching that i don't care what your
mother did
don't you want to make her pay i don't i
mean not really i'm kind of over it i'm
an adult now and i moved on i mean you
know people get bullied all the time in
high school you can't make it your
entire personality that would be crazy
end of netflix movie
should do each other's revenge okay i
like three fingers inside my revenge
we should do each other's revenge i'm
really mad at my penis you should choke
it
get revenge on my penis with your mouth
my penis killed your father
some guy walks in the movie's called do
revenge some guy walks in he goes which
one of you's revenge
or are you are you sisters is that a
last name because that's hot
[Music]
i want to burn her to the ground whoa
you're giving off some serious lesbians
what a [ __ ] goblin bro yeah
glenn close and fatal attraction energy
first off you wouldn't even get that
reference so shut up
energy
[Music]
[Music]
what is the point of this
for content for us at this point it
can't be for real people to consume
there's no way
just hear me out can i say something
i don't care if hunter biden had
children in his basement
okay this movie cannot come out
is that our new threshold yes i don't
care if turbiden had children in his
basement this movie cannot come out we
need to continue to have a conspiracy
yeah to stop this
i don't care if hunter biden has the
bodies of children in his basement this
is the best donut i have eaten
in my life in the last three years sam
harris just really got off the edge he
keeps comparing everything to hunter
biden's laptop
love it
you love it
see it's funny here let me explain you
guys don't get comedy it's funny because
lizards aren't supposed to wear
bathrobes and be on little couches no
but they're like obviously so posh yeah
they don't care
let's start with carissa she'll be a
cinch i can ruin her in my sleep why
will chris be easy it is much easier to
destroy a girl carissa right we've met
before you called me a human birkenstock
cool
that's another story i just want to say
how sorry i am for what happened to you
it's in your honor that i'm founding a
new club the cis
hetero men
championing
female identifying students league that
was actually the original name of the
show but burst was like revenge of the
sisters flashing her
it was a little wordy yeah
could we name this movie after the
people that are in it and just call this
movie pretty trash
or how about uh
hollywood's grown-up [ __ ]
you're going to expose
yourself
on camera for money
wait a second this movie's about cps
[Laughter]
that he's a fake woke misogynist
hypocrite and then
they took the worst parts of heather's
the worst parts of she's all that yes
there's parts of the [ __ ]
jawbreaker
literally took all like it's like they
watched all these classic 90s teen
movies for research but got
all the worst [ __ ] things out of each
one yeah it's like women wrote it right
they they only
you know you know what's funny i mean
what am i wrong
they only take they only take the rape
scene from revenge of the nerds that's
the only thing they take from it is the
the is the rape scene where he works
because by the way we can all agree it
is a race rape he raped her absolutely
yes
you're not serious no i'm not [ __ ]
serious
teenage girls we're psychopaths
well i mean okay
you grow up to be psychopaths too so
it's not because you're raised by
psychopaths and you're also born
psychopaths and then you write movies
where you glorify being psychopaths
and then we're going to make fun of it
and you're going to say that we're
misogynistic because you don't know how
to be funny
she framed me
hey hey can i make a guess sure
they accidentally kill someone
it
they accidentally kill somebody
i hope it's me
no you have to sit through it [ __ ] they
accidentally kill someone and then uh
yeah this is serious but one of them's
like no we need to do oh hi
[Music]
if there's 3d netflix movie they just
have somebody [ __ ] come out of the
screen and shoot you in your stupid
[ __ ] head
god willing
are you in therapy god no why
cool
[Music]
[Applause]
guys guys the blonde one the blonde one
is all dark and edgy right
but it turns out i bet you by the end of
it the like prissy dark-haired one turns
out that she's actually the crazy one
hey taper
can you make aw can you make a revenge
of the sis logo exactly like this one
oh [ __ ] thanks
do revenge of this is
it's not far awesome i know revenge even
like
correct can we see them i think we can
i feel like yeah can you lose a lawsuit
against netflix absolutely guys you
absolutely can uh excuse me it's called
barack obama's netflix you get it right
all right i'm sorry i forgot my barack
obama and david letterman and dave
chappelle present netflix
all right frozen brought to you did you
guys enjoy that last one no
no i didn't
i hated it frozen okay